[Musique]
la femme doit être libre de choisir le
nombre d'enfants qu'elle veut sacha
molus être libre de son corps c'est à
chalon hlm et fleurs elle doit être
sans changement le gore qui nourrit plus
tard que d'entendre et surtout des
hommes st chamond l'école mousseron
vous êtes démarre tout ce que ça
comporte d'amour pour s'achever au sol
de fait on en est encore au stade dire
qu'une femme parce qu'elle a un enfant
c'est une ordure là on est encore là
dans nos régions saint-chamond rue
principale
[Musique]
de femmes affirmant pourquoi
pour échanger ses idées entre femmes et
s'exprimer
entre femmes de problèmes de femme
pourquoi entre femmes
parce que les hommes sont là on n'a pas
souvent là par
les hommes vous en prie nous apprîmes
pomme alors conversations sont tellement
importantes que
ont passé une après midi ensemble ces
messieurs ont parlé tous leurs problèmes
et nous on s'aperçoit qu'on n'a pas pu
parler des livres en croissance il
différent ils sont différents justement
dans les problèmes de
contraception
l'avortement
ils sont différents même dans la vie
dans la vie publique parce qu'ils nous
prennent pas au sérieux que s'il y avait
un groupe mlf à saint-etienne j'ai
certainement j'y adhérais pour l'instant
nous sommes en recherche au sein d'un
groupe de femmes qui s'est donc
constitué comme ça parce qu'on a senti
qu'on a le désir de se regrouper et si
un jour il ya ce mouvement se crée sur
saint-etienne certainement plusieurs y
adhéreront seulement il leur faut une
étincelle il leur faut des personnes qui
leur donne la parole une femme libérée
c'est une femme qui a le droit d'avoir
une vie personnelle quel droit au
travail qui a le droit à avoir une vie
économique et enfin une vie économique
indépendante qui a le droit d'avoir une
république qui a le droit d'être un être
à part entière aussi qu'un homme aussi
bien connu
toute façon dans la résistance on a vu
des femmes se battre et c'est à partir
peut-être de ce monarque tout de même il
tombera le rendu compte qu'on n'était
pas toujours découpé et des objets à
faire des petits il va quand même autre
chose dans une femme vous en paierez
l'objet
mais j'ai surtout senti femmes à faire
les enfants
robert n'avez-vous 4
et vous madame
combien je vais faire moi hic le travail
et
je gagne 950 euros par mois pour
travailler côte à l'envi huit heures par
jour
40 heures par semaine et il consomme du
sauteur en touche vous estimez vous êtes
suffisamment payé ah non je suis payé
pour 5h d'accord pour lutter
pour cinq ans j'accepterais de
travailler dans des conditions comme ça
parce que huit heures ces trois pour une
femme c'est quoi
en fait pourquoi parce que
pour rester huit heures debout dans le
bruit
d'un bruit et puis la chaleur
ben c'est pas greenblatt magazine only
for me plaît pas du tout
mais je suis obligé c'est tout c'est
pour la paye que je vais
ça ne va pas du tout sa charge je vous
dirai pas ce qu'il ya peut-être on a des
copains de travail tout ça on peut
discuter qu'un disque à la maison on
discute à personne voilà
ça fait combien d'heures de travail
d'argent c'est enfin de l'usiné puis le
travail la maison
toujours
bien 14 heures on a bien oui plus
finalement le travail est beaucoup plus
que nos travail ventech peut-être lui
d'un ménage sur même parce qu'il peut
pas tout faire un homme ne pas tout
faire pourquoi donc pas ce que c'est ce
temps les a pas habitués de brossard nos
mères
j'ai toujours fait des ménages depuis
l'âge de 15 ans jusqu'à 26 ans et sans
être déclarés et puis alors je sais pas
la campagne
mais si je faisais des journées comme ça
je vais chez les malins qui avaient des
petits enfants je faisais des conscrits
si vous avez
wissam sorte chez moi j'ai repris mon
métier parce que je voulais me prouver à
moi même qu'à 46 ans pourrait reprendre
son travail sa vie professionnelle c'est
un métier que j'aime énormément le
métier d'infirmière alors il se posait à
moi lorsque mes enfants étaient venus
plus grands femme de médecin et j'ai
cinq enfants ils y sont en hd
seul et ensuite je pensais que j'avais
un apport
donner à la société je la profession
leur être utile à la société autre que
dans mon ménage et dans ma vie de mère
de famille en fait j'ai toujours était
d'ailleurs plutôt féministe si vous
voulez je pense à l'égalité foncière de
l'homme et de la femme et sur tous les
plans d'ailleurs même sur le plan sexuel
que sur l'autre malgré tout le passé
effectivement un qui conditionne la
femme et qu'il a fait paraître un petit
peu inférieur je crois sont égalité
fondamentale on n'a jamais voulu faire
une dîme à trillard caso j'appelle une
supériorité de la femme se nomme que
steve a plusieurs qui me disent bon ben
maintenant la réaction c'est de dire
vous voulez être supérieure à l'homme
alors que gilles danger n'est pas encore
là donc ça on l'a toujours dit entre
lula et moi même j'ai vu énormément de
jeunes femmes engagés dans des
mouvements féministes et j'ai encore
jamais entendu une femme me dire je veux
être supérieure à l'homme l'écraser
alors je dis le danger du matriarcat
n'est pas encore là mais je pense que
nous l'avons nous mêmes nous avons à
réinventer la femme d'aujourd'hui et
pour qu'elle soit celle de demain non je
parle ce que la société elle est surtout
faite par les hommes les lois sont
votées par les hommes
toutes façons la société audi la société
nous opprime mais la société sont les
zones en réalité qui elle qui est ce que
la majorité au parlement qui en majorité
au sénat allez expliquer à un député
qu'il faut des crèches qu'il faut il n'y
a pas dans le bain pour le comprendre
alors les doigts les lois sont votées un
signe mais en réalité dans la vie
journalière de la femme eh ben
il faudrait que ces messieurs denis
dessein a dit journalisme la femme et
moi je dis la société la société on part
toujours d'un faux site et mais qui a
fait la société qui qui fait les lois
anti qui sont bien les hommes
pourquoi y at il si peu de femmes
députées en france selon vous c'est une
question qui revient souvent
et
on peut se poser la question de savoir
pourquoi un homme est toujours
embarrassé de répondre je vous dirai
peut-être que c'est une tradition qui
veut que les hommes se sont toujours
plus préoccupés de la vie tic que les
femmes
elles votent bien sûr l on en droit et
elle devrait je pense
être souvent plus représentés dans les
différentes assemblées locales
départementales et nationales
c'est une mamie de l'homme sur la
politique que les changes et par
tellement de loi qui permet justement
comme vous disiez pas tellement de loi
qui ont permis de construction des
crèches la construction de au point de
vue social par exemple au point de vue
social il ya ce sont des exemples qui
font les lois sociales c'est une
demoiselle célibataire
est-ce qu'elle pourra comprendre est-ce
qu'elle pourra contraire le rôle
lui mais qu'à quatre enfants qui
voudraient aller travailler qui
voudraient mettre ses enfants dans une
crèche parce que si elle ne comprenait
les crèches train de piller par 4 par 10
par an il n'y a pas de crèche en plus
ici il n'ya pas de crèche c'est vrai il
en faudrait c'est certes un
shooting voir cependant dans la
réalisation de crèches une solution au
problème de faux qui peuvent être posées
aux femmes de notre région
personnellement je ne pense pas c'est
une commodité qui lorsqu'à offerte
appréciable certainement et qui pourrait
rendre dutil services communs elle en
réclame elle en réclame c'est vrai et
je crois que un certain nombre
d'initiatives
pourront se concrétiser si j'en crois
certains projets en cours d'étude
six mois après certaines choses par
hasard si je veux m'offrir le coiffeur
il arrivera il est vrai qu'il est
tellement un petit traitement que
vous payez pas faim
je lui dis je vis dijon croit fort
évidemment me julie la moitié du prix
je me débrouille en faisant passer dans
les frais généraux de la chasse
sait pas exactement ce n'est pas trop
c'est la grâce
à la fois la valeur actuelle c'est la
gratte ciels cali débrouiller comme je
peux
faire pression les culottes dans votre
ménage à barres ou barbade a toujours
dit pour quand même
bien sur certains points à quel point de
vue augmentés la culotte savait par tout
ce qu'on a entre 27 août
qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait
d'avoir une femme tellement féministe
mais je vous dis que quand je me suis
marié j'ai quitté ma mère pour être
libre elle est finalement loi que les
femmes ça rien du tout même si ça
s'arrête pour sa caisse conduit à man où
les hommes
je me demande mais c'est énorme
alors je fais déjà la vaisselle passamar
d'efforts et tout le fourbi
maintenant
je suis à l'abri au boulot vous avez vu
madame martine aujourd'hui dans les
faits divers sur le projet doctoresse
grenoble trois membres d'une association
plein de familles l inculpé d'avortement
500 avortements ont été pratiqués ainsi
mme round
qu'est ce que vous en pensez laverhne
ou en jeu parce que normalement il
aurait continué très vite et que de
toute façon la femme est libre de ton
corps qu'est-ce que vous inventez nous
moi je suis couvre pour l'avortement
vois ça n'arriverait personnellement
mais bon jeu favori vous prenez la
pilule non parce que mon mari va pas
vous mais autrement moi je suis pour un
tout à fait pourquoi vous voulez pas
qu'on en arrive là bas se développe
parce qu'une femme qui pourraient
figurer
je sais pas parce que sa tâche était
libre et plus du monde oui je savais pas
qu'elle vous trompe oui oui peut-être
cette débauche main franchement qu'elle
me trompe pas ce que j'ai vu ce que la
tendance de femme ou une fille qui prend
la pilule et qui fait qu'ils sont les
moins d'avoir des rares fois que
n'importe qui de flirter avec n'importe
qui pour mieux prendre la pilule sapress
retrouver avec
par exemple pour une femme mariée c'est
bien la pilule je trouve pas ce que
parce que mes temps c'est là deux
enfants ils sont plus heureux que nous
fâcher pas si la nasa coupant du
matériel si elle disait rien à mark de
wind à cornes et s'il n'est pas mariée à
baisser les pas mariés ou de l'api le
site presque l'enfant
il est pas il n'est pas heureux si la
plupart il est peut-être heureux mais
c'est se parle de frais lui
vous en pensez moi je suis contre la
pilule
parce que je pense que le marié la
famille doivent savoir se restreindre
s'il le faut et pour les jeunes filles
qui sont qu'ils sont pas mariés elle
aussi elle doit sera stands jusqu'à ce
qu'elles sont mariées si elles le
veulent vous êtes contre la liberté
sexuelle alors pourquoi
parce que ça la plupart du temps ça
porte des malheurs lieu d'apporter du
bonheur n'était surtout mal informés
d'abord la contraception dans nos
régions il n'y a rien pour expliquer la
contraception qu'on reparle nous n'avons
absolument rien absolument rien rien n'y
fait à peu près le seul médecin de laval
et angers quelques uns viennent et qui
font partie du botanique familiale donc
si vous voulez qu'ils sont favorables
non seulement une exécution mais une
propagande sur le plan de la
contraception donc je vois quand même
certainement une grande partie de deux
femmes qui prennent la pilule il y en a
très peu et effectivement il ya une
répression à peu près moi si vous voulez
j'ai peut-être je pas une cenne 120
dossiers quoi de femmes qui prennent la
pilule quoi donc pour une population de
40 en gros quoi le secteur qu'on
recouvre sa fais 30000 habitants quoi
oui c'est très très peu très très peu
parce qu'au point de vue contraception a
toujours parlé de la contraception
les femmes on n'a jamais parlé de la
contraception pour les hommes et à ce
sujet me tient beaucoup expliqué la
femme supporte tout insupporte la
grossesse elle supporte la lettre même
si c'est la lettre elle supporte les
appareils soient stérilet souan payfair
on les supporte dans ses organes
internes elle supporte la haye supporte
la pilule s il faut à la réalité en
arriver aux commandes elle appelle ça la
ligature des trompes et supportent
encore la souffrance est supporter la
souffrance de l'accouchement et il
faudrait qu'elle supporte la souffrance
de l'avortement
et ces messieurs sont bien bien prendre
moi je trouve au point de vue avortement
ce genre de 100 couronnes compte ainsi
parce que le foetus honneur demain il
n'y a rien à faire c'est non moi je sais
pas
charest je suis un peu à la bourre
d'histoire
on a vous êtes pour ou contre la
contraception la contraception mois se
supporte pas tellement vous êtes
contraint suis pas tellement pour bien
sûr la famille c'est la famille faisait
des quatre enfants ce que vous les avez
vous lu tous les quatre oui on les
environs nous avons eu une enfance
ouvert aujourd'hui comme ça on les a
voulu manger j'aimais beaucoup les
enfants qui avant mon mariage et les
dégâts sont décisives mais enfin total
en bois vous prenez la pilule non
pourquoi parce que je le prends drogués
et puis je ne prends ni contraintes que
les jours attendent quelque chose pour
notre peuple maintenant j'ai verte d'un
étranglement jeu parfait si vous avez un
cinquième enfant
oui je l'accepterais pas encore bien sûr
mais je ne ferai pas voter parce que moi
j'ai eu les autres leurs autres
postulats alors moi ya une chose que je
n'admets pas dans la région c'est
l'hypocrisie alors là je vais vous dire
je m'excuse mais je vais beaucoup la
religion nous faut dans la tête qu'en
sais tu sais quand même un être vivant
elle fait jamais rien pour les guerres
au monde admet qu'on veut quand on veut
porter un être vivant en foetus de
quelques semaines alors que j'ai vu
aucun aucun prêtre aucun évêque personne
du matin absolument personne s'élever
contre des dégâts après tain qu'on
envoie à l'abattoir sa mort l'hypocrisie
je peux plus le supporter je te furax
pourquoi parce que j'ai entendu matin là
les textes de mon homme parle j'ai parlé
d'abord tout est alors alors j'adore
rapport au premier
on va le connais on dit tant pis on dit
ce qu'on passe puis cinq chanteurs du
matin j'ai entendu encore sous le choc
lundi conservatoire de l'église de saint
benoît il avait trois handicaps
demande c'est que cela est extrêmement
avancé bowman monseigneur matin le nom
d'un membre
ses hobbies arrive bien sûr ces ports
sata est ce que vous êtes pour
l'ajustement du prix pratiqués devraient
avoir calé
sur tout cas d'accord il faut des corps
libre et gratuit je crois oui on en
avait discuté beaucoup oui je crois que
ça fait c'est un problème important
alors effectivement nous dit on peut pas
faire une loi qui est qui tel que
l'avortement soit libre et gratuit parce
qu'il ya des gens qui sont contre très
bien mais alors ils se feront pas
avorter dont l'europe les rares les
obligera ben simon faudra alors très
jeune à une autre vous qui s'est déjà
fait avorter
ok
mais si j'avais allons vous allez
débattre à l'assemblée nationale d'un
projet de loi sur la contraception est
là et l'avortement et il n'y a
pratiquement que des hommes à
l'assemblée nationale vous trouvez ça
normal
je trouve abusif que ce soit une
assemblée d'hommes qui décide du sort
des femmes sur un problème comme celui
aussi de l'homme comment est-ce que vous
élevez votre dernière fille qui a 15 ans
le siècle maintenant il a tout changé
mais enfin pas jugé sur rtl
si j'ai pas eu moi aussi avec carte du
parti régis marseille c'est tout juste
si ma mère m'a pas compagnie
dimanche une chaîne agnès est mon club
dans ses spots à la dickens
donc
non parce que pour moi personnellement
qui est encore un peu jeune et son plus
petit que moi
ben oui mais je pense qu'à l'heure
actuelle il ya je suis danger l'enfant
encore autour il ya beaucoup d'énergie
peux tu dire la vérité j'ai peur
que tu rencontres un jour un gars que tu
flore et qui te fasse souffrir ce qu'il
te fasse souffrir tu est pas encore
assez armé c'était je crois que je pense
à ces murs à c'est mieux pour distinguer
le vrai du faux
elle doit sa copie ils ont tous les deux
mais pamiers alors s'il bat agnes ivan
ces méthodes lorsque sa maman est comme
un peu comme le mans battu maintenant
elle est pas pareil humanisme profond
les duels de balle
nous candidats
avec des
majors
alors aussi n'est toutefois pas du tout
à dire non et pourquoi cela formait un
repli
toujours la même pour la même chose
[Musique]
qui me soit tu m'as total de jacqueline
angers eh bien oui parce que c'est vrai
par bataille pour tablettes récemment
c'est paul j'ai pas confiance 1 pour ma
part si j'ai confiance alors les j'ai
peur j'ai peur de voir ses fruits j'ai
peur de voir tes silences j'ai peut-être
de tintin déploré un jour dans sa
chambre j'ai peur de tout ça j'ai
pauvres c'est une chance
baby essayer maintenant tu me dis qu'il
me dit à des copains et c'était comme un
bourgeois à l'heure actuelle c'est tous
depuis des fleurs se dit copa est bas
mais j'ai bien dormi comme n1b sport
mais n'appelle futuriste il est attaché
avec ses copains tu as un bébé attendant
bébé au fait usa serait l'apport de
cathy et c'est ça qui doit te faire
comprendre ses portes à l'autoritarisme
malgré le crois pas ce uniquement pour
ça mais aussi que c'est un pas très bien
quoi faire sans moi
mais toi toi qui est si rémy nice tu
pourquoi tu reproche en fait tu
interdire tout l'accord des cas notre
enfance on est un frère tu me dire oui
c'est à dire que moi je trouve par des
guerres comme l'avortement moi je suis
tout à fait pour je suis tout à fait
pour tu auras 17 ans je te dit
arriverait quelque chose comme ça tu
voudrais pas imposer de gore où il
arrivera crûment de ta situation où tu
voudrais pas la fin alors moi je serais
tout à fait pour tu m'entends tu t'es
dit pierre seule la même pour la
contraception moi je pense que tu es
trop jeune tu es trop jeune parce que tu
as à 14h30 15h tu auras toute ta vie si
tu veux rester indépendante à voir le
nombre d'enfants que tu veux ou tu veux
que tu a jugé d'en avoir deux touchés
dans la voix remplie général marc 3 et
après que ce top niveau d'un mois en ça
me regarde c'est mon corps ça me regarde
oui métaux lui qui trinque tort tu tapes
apporte comme pour moi mais lyon parce
que c'est par lui d'abord et pourtant
elle pourrait bien arriver la même chose
mais c'est ce que je te dis lui porte
pas les femmes ça se voit pas comment
serait quoi toi alors ce serait face à
leurs efforts de jus ce qu'on dirait
j'aurais pas venu entendu quand durera
tant que membre du canadien que j'aurais
portelli fait contre à menton serrés
fait plus de soixante situation c'est
que tu absolue marié toute seule pour
élever à lens un ton frère lui et ils
portent pas neuf mois il aura toujours
sa situation et s'en moquent éperdument
la différence encore entre hommes et
femmes tu comprends
bien encore il faut se battre pour
arriver à l'égalité il faudra battre toi
aussi comme nous on se bat maintenant
j'ai les rationnements pour arriver
parce que la femme ait les mêmes droits
du moment qu'elle a des devoirs d'avoir
les mêmes droits il ya pas de train de
mitonner voilà qu'est ce que vous pensez
du féminisme de votre mère ben la petite
peuvent ouvrir ses enfants comment vous
pour rencontrer le garçon
non à l'école toute la journée
et comme on est vivant à saint chamond
pour rencontre les garçons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
et
dans ma cuisine
g voici ce que nous apprend finalement
que le patron chez les cadets c'est
la fatigue
mais voyez pas de solution vous
ressortir
pour pour sortir de je puisse vous
travaillez que fut ce livre bien vivre
et je sais pas comment ils revivent
pour sortir de ça puisque vous n'avez
pas là tellement heureuse
oui mesdames était comme elle doit être
et comment sortir
par évolution pour égaler ferme envers
la religion
les familles parce que si ça continue
comme ça contre aubry met
la main sur le maire je vois comme ça
bon les pneus je peux me tromper mais
surtout mais
je crois plus aux élections lorsque les
élections chanson décrit j'ai chaque
fois on arrive à magouiller on sait plus
où on allait à la fin
j'y crois pas non plus tard
je ne parviens pas trop pour pas ce qui
se passe dans les usines actuellement
moi je crois la révolte à la nivelle
d'amis
mais vous pensez que c'est un public à
l'imaginaire français sans faire la
révolution on voit les fans français je
pense pas sortie seule dans les rangs
français non il faut pas quand même où
on se fait passer pour des petites et
des illuminés des petites annonces et
des centrales avant sommes partis
ensemble
ça va d'ailleurs écouter les choses ont
tellement devenir injuste les prix
montent avec des petits salaires il ya
tellement des mêmes et sont en train de
la préparer la révolution ce qui
critères qu'ils n'en veulent pas
[Musique]